- [Instructor] We are
told to use estimation
to tell whether each estimated quotient
is reasonable or unreasonable.
So we have a bunch of
estimated quotients here.
Someone is estimating that
2,419 divided by three
is roughly equal to 7,500
and we have to figure out
is that reasonable or unreasonable?
And then we have two more
quotients to figure out
if it's unreasonable or reasonable.
Pause this video
and see if you can
figure it out on your own
before we work through it together.
All right, now let's
work through it together.
The way that I'd like to tackle this
is just try to do the estimation myself.
I'll start with this first one.
2,419 divided by three.
One way to estimate
is try to think about what
numbers are these close to
that are a little bit
easier to compute with.
Some people would say they're
a little bit friendlier
so to speak.
Well three is already
a pretty simple number
a pretty friendly number.
2,419, well it's a little
bit more complicated.
But I could try to think of
is there there a multiple of
three that's close to 2,419
that is a fairly friendly number?
I do know that three times eight is 24.
So if I had something like 2,400
which is the same thing as 2,400
that'd be easy to divide by three.
So I could say that
this is roughly equal to
2,400 divided by three.
All I did is I said, hey
2,419 for estimation purposes
let's just say it's
roughly equal to 2,400.
And then 2,400 is fairly
straightforward to divide by three.
This over here
24 divided by three is eight
so 2,400 divided by three is 800.
This is going to be 800.
So 2,419 divided by three
should be roughly around 800.
They're saying that it's roughly 7,500.
That's a lot more than 800.
If they said 750
then I'd say, hey that's
pretty reasonable.
But they're saying 7,500.
That's almost 10 times more than 800
so, this I would say is unreasonable.
All right, let's think about this next one
and again, pause the video
and see if you can have a go at it.
All right, I'm just going
to try to estimate again.
So 435 divided by five.
Let's say that's roughly equal to.
An easy multiple of
five that's close to 435
if I wanna think of a friendly number
it might be 400.
So I'll say that's roughly
equal to 400 divided by five.
Now, we know that 40 divided by five is
is eight, sorry.
And so 40 10s divided
by five is eight 10s.
So this is going to be equal to 80.
And you could think
about it the other way.
Five times eight 10s is going to be 40 10s
which is the same thing as 400.
This thing should be roughly equal to 80.
Well, that's exactly what we estimated
so that feels very reasonable.
All right, this last one.
Pause the video again, see
if you can have a go at that.
All right, so we have
6,202 divided by two.
We could say that's approximately equal to
or roughly equal to.
Well, if I just wanted
to do it very roughly
I could say, hey 6,202
let's just go to 6,000
just to make things really easy.
Divided by two.
And so this is going to be
six 1000s divided by two
would be three 1000s or 3,000.
But here they have 300.
That's one tenth of what I have over here.
So this is unreasonable.
And we're done.